is
oh
hello anesthesia
bastard tried to mug me i handled it
oh local guy you really think somebody
local will try to bug me pepe
listen v i got a problem serious this
time
find yourself a hole sounds like you
need help
i know i could count on you it's a
cork i owe him don't pay by tomorrow
said he bust my legs
he don't joke about that stuff got
cartel's in his corner
every man woman and rat in haywood knows
he's a [ __ ] shark
my bro jumped the joint deserve the
hero's welcome
i know i [ __ ] up feet
i'll talk to kirk but then you're gonna
owe me one
on yourself
demons walk with me
a
[Music]
hey cook wanna talk
v been a while spin it what you need
pepe asked me to talk you up
what he too shot a hand over the yetis
herself ah tell him i don't fight
not yet
how's your problem
what's yo afraid that's client
confidentiality
call it a lot and leave it at that a
cred shark with
business ethics sounds too good to be
true
well merry [ __ ] christmas
cut him some slack will you you pay
just need some more time
do i look like a priest that runs a
charity to you
you borrow eddie's you gotta pay him
back with
interest it's common [ __ ] knowledge
are you suggesting i let a flaky [ __ ]
who can't keep a deal off the hook
no you let him off because it's me
asking
you know me i'm a man of the bids so i
need to know
what i get out of it you know what kirk
i sometimes get the impression you
forget you aren't from around here
pop into haywood for the occasional
visit sure
but you live far far away in pacifica
what are you getting at getting that
you're probably needing to think
before you start something with the
local sun
i'm open to other options
cream ride there on the page only four
of them in nc as of now
one rayfield regional director two
mayor ryan three a rental service
uh-huh and four number four will belong
to my client
just as soon as you clap it for me that
is
i do this pepe's debt is squared
of course i'm a man of my word you know
that
all things simple you swipe the ray
field for me
i clear pepe's account even toss in a
cut for you i'm such a nice guy
my man rick works a parking structure by
embers club where a rayfield driver
likes to kick it
there every friday night like clockwork
as soon as you appear
security cam shut down gate swings up
the road is yours
just gotta grab the ray field and roll
out simple
how am i supposed to do this expect me
to slide under the chassis on a
skateboard for a quick hot wire
fast and easy kirk wheels like this got
security systems
good ones
this biddybop works like the key
rayfield techs use for repairs
opens locks bypasses identity
authorization
a skeleton key for all ray fields in the
city
come on kirk even you don't buy
kabuki's tech wizards sell more magical
[ __ ] than this
under the counter have a little faith
so we all agreed then
best keep your word perfect easy v
jobs gonna pad your wallet too you know
head to embers in the glen
rick's in the garage
you two will hit it off good luck out
there
we'll be in touch
[Music]
[Music]
the boxer please
[Music]
[Music]
hello
fat ass [ __ ] hey why do i see
no goddamn lemons no god i can afford
they're in there for sure no
money's got nothing to do
who do we have here we
long time didn't know you were around
got back from atlanta a few weeks ago
see you got a good down home welcome
how was it back east tell you later got
something on my plate
how about you from here we'll give you a
ride
marcus let's go
drop me off at embers front door
take the ramp back at the bar show you
where to stop
you heard it marcus
[Music]
your return to nc has been good
busy already yeah
pick up something here and there nothing
major
but i'm getting by appreciate the
concern
so i'd like that it didn't turn out like
you expected huh
as you can see i'm back i've been better
there
wouldn't have left maybe it'll all work
out for the best
[ __ ]
stop the car what's going on
business you carrying
sebastian ivara looks like it's my lucky
day
what do you want to settle our biz
once and for all got an offer for you
paddy
so listen up get the [ __ ] out of vista
pull your boys off the street
i'll give you the glenn done deal no
more restless nights
see how generous i can be
well one more [ __ ] word stay out of
this
i don't know you and i don't know you
which means you're with [ __ ] around here
and capable of even less
well anything else it seems our
conversation has come to a close
careful padre never know who's got a
barrel at your six
you neither [ __ ] bucket marcus please
i am pleased to see you have not
forgotten
so many of the little shits left around
here their spines go soft when they look
down the barrel
who was that no one important
he'll be gone in a week's time another
will come in this place
he pulled iron on you he did
and he will pay for doing so
[Music]
pull up here right here i'll just drop
down below
here before you go
your number could be useful
maybe we can also work together again
take ourselves back two years
thanks padre gotta go
so go with god
i'll be damned
what's up
you uh want something chum
hmm [ __ ] this country
v status on location
about to find your man rick's one of the
good guys you'll see
i trust him like a brother
[Music]
so
yeah something i can help you with
[Music]
kirk sent me mm-hmm
camera's blind you got 20 minutes
[Music]
do your thing
kirk i see the ride your moment to shine
kiddo
good luck
let's take this piece of wonder tech for
a whirl
you're a man of little faith see
we're rich now fire up and call me when
you're underway
tell you where to go
looks like this will be a cool breeze
get the [ __ ] up
oh [ __ ] you can drive now
[Music]
you're under arrest
[Music]
jackie wells my old pal from the hood
i see you haven't grown an owl twice
hey detective stance
been a while huh inspectors same [ __ ]
speaking of your mug's familiar too
come on spit it out
left for atlanta looking for a slice of
happiness
yes you didn't find it i've always
maintained it's the same for all you
termites in haywood born here
live here die here looks like i was
right
rat got your tongue enough of the
chatter what now
get booked gonna do a stint
get it come on stance give us a break
huh
you lock us up let's just jerk off till
trial
and then what worst case
we get some standing room only nowadays
oh they'll probably be out early
are these the thieves 40 street trash
got him in custody mr fujioka we'll be
taking them now
it's a waste of effort i have no time to
testify or play it under investigation
suggesting we let him go sir i suggest
you toss them in the seat
conflict's broken so this trash doesn't
float
you heard him [ __ ]
mother [ __ ]
honestly for a sector things looked iffy
i wasn't sure we'd worm out of that
alive
and same stints is hard to get people
wow i'm tight
though he does have a little honor left
really think his sense of honor saved us
well and the fact he's haywood born and
bred like us
if i hadn't come you'd be cruising night
city in sexy wheels right now
ah come on job was toxic from the start
even kabuki under the counter magic
can't get around an alarm like that
should have known i'd have the pd on my
ass
so maybe now has god ordained
jackie wells vee
i know you you hang at the coyote
wait wells like mama wells
thought i'd recognize the name it's my
blood all right
coyotes her dive it's strange you and i
never met before
got the job to steal those wheels at the
coyote from kirk
you work with that sewer slug pepe
wasn't big he can't afford to pay so
i stepped up man
gotta wonder about pepe letting slimy
kirk boss him around like that
heard what they say he's backed by
cartels
cartels no no listen
i know those cartel times and i
guarantee you none of them
have even heard of kirk el cabrone's
gotta learn
you don't do people in here with dirty
come on
let's go have some lunch
lunch you would not believe my mama's
chili
best in town
getting one of my good feelings about
what
about us this is the kind of chemistry
you know
come on i'm [ __ ] starved okay
food it is let's go
hello there night city
[Music]
stanley here with you and we got another
day ahead of us in this
city of dreams oh i love this town
love it like you might love a mother who
popped you out on the steps of an
orphanage once
and now stops you to ask if you got a
smoke for her
[Music]
every new day here means a hundred new
arrivals
but only half these gods will survive a
year and that's if it's a good one
and why do these peeps come to nc well
to be
street samurai like morgan black hand
and whalen boa boa
the greater the risk the bigger the kids
or so they say but you can only be a
major league player for
so long the faster you live the faster
you burn out
if you don't get a bullet to the brain
first
[Music]
nc's legends know where you'll find most
of
the
them
[Music]
matters not where you're from matters
not where you
start what matters here is the walk you
walk in night city
the city of dreams
chick we're looking for somewhere in
this building
probably crawling with the peniles that
kidnapped her eyes and ears open all
right
speaking of which got you a little
something
militech training shard in case you need
to uh
brush up on your dance moves down for
some target practice in vr
sure why the hell not